we've talked about the random drug
testing of welfare recipients in the
United States before there's a strain of
right-wingers that like the idea of
testing welfare recipients for drug use
with the idea that if someone receiving
welfare benefits is on drugs then they
should have their welfare benefits cut
either partially or completely in some
cases and the Australian government now
is going to do a two-year test of
randomly testing 5000 welfare applicants
for drug use they're going to start this
program in January and this would
require these 5,000 applicants and
eventual recipients of Australian
welfare to do random saliva urine or
hair drug tests and the tests would be
for a variety of drugs and includes meth
MDMA which is the key component in
ecstasy marijuana heroin as well as
other drugs what would happen if they
test positive well 80% of their welfare
benefit money would be moved to what is
called a basicscard which can only be
used to pay for food rent childcare and
other essential items presumably the
idea is it would prevent them from being
able to take welfare money and use it to
buy drugs if they test positive more
than once
they will then be referred to a medical
professional for addiction treatment
there are two aspects of this that I
want to discuss with you one is moral
and one is more pragmatic first is the
morality right to believe that it's
moral to drug test welfare recipients
and then sanction or reduce their
welfare benefits based on a positive
drug test result you sort of by
definition have to support the failed
war on drugs and the criminalization of
drugs what do I mean by that cigarettes
and alcohol are legal right so you don't
hear people saying well test welfare
recipients for cigarette and alcohol use
and if they test positive then cut their
benefits because those are legal
regulated substances so in order to make
the moral case that drug use should lead
to the removal of welfare benefits or
the sanctioning of 80 percent of those
benefits on a basicscard or whatever you
have to at least to some degree believe
in the concept of illicit or illegal
and the prosecution of such drugs in
some version of a war on drugs context
especially because those costs can often
be compatible to I mean marijuana versus
alcohol maybe costs around the same
alright measuring but you can't just not
like one significantly more expensive
right you can't make the case that well
no the problem with marijuana is it's
way more people spend way more on
marijuana than they do on alcohol no
it's not necessarily true at all and
we've talked about that endlessly right
and it's pretty difficult to convince
people on moral issues so instead of
focusing too much on that even though
obviously the war on drugs has been a
major failure let's talk pragmatically
for a moment fiscally since many people
who support this type of testing are
fiscal conservatives they don't like the
idea of spending welfare money on drug
users for financial reasons seven states
in the u.s. have tried similar programs
where drug test there were drug tests of
welfare recipients and the argument is
the way you save money is you drug test
welfare recipients and then you take
away their welfare benefits so even
though the drug tests cost something
you're saving way more by not paying
drug users welfare benefits seven states
did this Arizona Kansas Mississippi
Missouri Oklahoma Tennessee and Utah
they piloted programs like these the
results have been completely definitive
and unanimous in two ways number one
write this one down the drug use rate
among welfare recipients has been lower
than the drug use rate of the general
population in other words if you
randomly drug test will pick Utah if you
randomly drug test Utah residents they
will have a higher drug use rate than
when you randomly drug test Utah welfare
recipients the random residents will use
drugs at a higher rate than the welfare
recipients that's interesting sort of
logical to if you're applying for
welfare benefits you presumably have
less disposable income you're less
likely to go and spend money on drugs
okay but number two as a result of the
low drug use rate among welfare
recipients and applicants the cost of
the drug testing in these tests has
exceeded the savings from kicking the
drug users off of welfare in other words
Missouri spent three hundred and thirty
six thousand dollars drug testing about
thirty nine thousand people only forty
eight people tested positive
drugs which would not save you the money
that the entire drug testing program
cost and similar results around the
country it's bogus well I mean
specifically when it comes to Australia
is pushing for this right I mean at
least they're not going to just kick
people off of their welfare back okay
they're doing in some US states I mean
there's this first round where the
welfare money that you get has to be
allocated towards rent or towards food
or what have you and then the second
strike is having to go to some medical
health professional to deal with the
addictions so right even even in its
worst light Australia ranks better than
some US states here you're not wrong but
that basicscard where 80% of your
welfare benefits are transferred that is
part of the script sketchy crony
capitalism that is often in the
background of these ideas those basics
cards are administered by a company that
is a system that requires infrastructure
and implementation and of course the
company that administers those cards has
connections to Australian politicians
sort of another story right separate
from the idea of drug testing welfare
recipients but crony capitalism always
in the background and correct me if I'm
wrong but Australian politicians are
also on the public dollars yes there
should they not be drug tested as well I
mean if the idea is we don't want our
tax dollars going to people who are
going to turn around and spend that
money on drugs
maybe cops bureaucrats politicians
should also be drug tested you know the
same arguments been made in the United
States I agree total non-starter
I mean laughable laughable non-starter
the video you just watched was made
possible by support from you please go
to patreon.com slash david pakman show
you can make a pledge of as little as
one dollar per month and every dollar
helps to support the work that we're
doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad